Evet şekerim sümelya İlgin belki
sümerlerde falan da bilmiyorsun Ben
öğretmenim bir tane Fakültesi açıldı bu
çok önemli Düzü Ankara'da Dil ve Tarih
Coğrafya fakültesinin açılması Ben gelen
herkese ne yapıp yapıp bunu anlatıyorum
Çünkü maalesef benim şey yapmalarına
baktım Bu Atatürk'e gelen kitaplardan
bile Bugün tam yazmıyorlar Yani
dil-tarih bu fakültesinin amacının ne
olduğunu hiçbirisi söylemediniz bir kez
daha söyler misin Onu bir kez daha çocuk
kurduğu buldum bu fakültenin anlamı
böyle amacı
bu Türk dili Türk tarihi Türk kültürü
üzerinde araştıracak Uzmanlar
yetiştirmek hücreli Siz orayı ne zaman
bitirdiniz Ekim'de o orada Türk
kültürünü falan Nereden bulacaktı bu
Uzmanlar nerede çalışırdı Türklerle
ilgili olan bütün milletlerin dilleri
resim türler oluyor kodlar onlar neyle
Çin King İran Rus Macar şey Arap Zeki
Yunan Bütün bunların gecekondu acıkli
bir şey de vardı Bu arada da bunlardan
Türklerin kökeni araştırılacaktır
güncellenen Ne var orada Atatürk
bu bitki Fransızca kitapta okumuş Kendi
gözümle gördüm diyor küstüm Eller Orta
Asya'da gelmiş olabilirler Gülleri
Türk'ü ne benziyor Atatürk altı için
Işık altında çizmiş yemleri Türk diline
benziyor altında çizmiş beyanına kocaman
bir önemli yazmış yani eski harfli eski
diyeceğim müziğim yazmışım şeyde ve onun
için döktübu fakülteye Bir de Smart loji
konacak şişmiş hiçbir şey çünkü acaba
Türklerle bir şey Miraç bitti var mı bu
araştırsın diye Ondan sonra o arada bak
30'larda düşün Şeyh ateş eden şey
yapıldı kazı yapıldığı hititlerin şeyi
bulun
bu illerin sözcüğü nedir öğrenmiş
Atatürk kocaman bir devlet kurmuşlar
Anadolu'da Hititler acaba bunlar da
Türklerle bilgisi var mı bu çocuğu şık
olacak Yani bütün milletlerin arasında
yük dönüşü ve sıvı ruju dillerinde
kültürü Atatürk oluyor bundan sonra akıl
üşüdü atıp oluşu buna sonra Şevval
eklenir bir şey daha var böyle böylece
bir para paket program yükleme ama 4 bu
çocuklar geçişme yetiş'le gidem
izleyecekler mi bir gidecekler Para
nereden bulacaksın işte onlar da değil
Mesaj kurumlarını yapıyor kendi cebinden
sermayesi veririm eve Anlatabildim mi
böyle bir paket program yaz
bu Türk tarihi Türk kültürünü
araştıracak bir paket program bütün
gayesi bu bunu maalesef unuturlar
unutulmuşlar Yok efendim iki saattir şey
sosyal bilimler diyorlar Yani bu şey
amacından uzaklaşan uzaklaştırmış şimdi
nasıl girdiniz bu Evet fakülte Biz
öğretmenlik öğretmenleri bir kere
limassol bakıcı kabul ettiler yani
öğretmenler Ankara'dan rica etmiş
Atatürk'e bize bir kerelik oraya girelim
bu müsaade veriyor ben de işte Ondan biz
iki arkadaş gel cici kızlar Biz paldır
küldür akıllı gitti
eve gittik dediler ki şey nereye Ben
Fırat istedim arkadaşlar böyle ha
dediler dolu Onlar biraz geç gitmişiz
gelin hocası yeni gelir daha yeni
başlayan Biz geçmiş yetiştik başlayan
bir şey var bölüm var hititoloji bölümü
Oraya gideceksin yapıyorsun arkadan
yanına sömürücü yardımcı değil aşkoloji
yüksekliğine tarih kazanım günler Peki
oldu dedik bizim kaldırdık çıktık
arkadaşımın annesi diyoruz değil
Rojin'in bir şey ifade ettiğini bile
bilmiyor bizim ifade etti o kadar cahil
ve ona tabi girdik ki baktı kılo hocalar
yabancı dil yabancı defa cisim
o yıllar Bir de Hem çiviye sen neşeli
ediyorsunuz Ne İbranice başarısı
ibranicede Hayır Ayşe İbrahim Yüce de
yazılıyor onu da gözüküyorlar beyhatın
böyle şaşkına geldik ama neyse çalışınca
şey oluyor başardık çıktık gitti lan ne
yaptı da bu kadar üzerinde çalışacak
hale geldiği insanlar yani neden bu
kadar ilgilendiğiniz Siz alanınız
olmasının ötesinde Çünkü bir şeyler
yakaladınız Sümerler birşeyleri alt üst
ettiler Ne yaptılar onu biraz söyler
misiniz Anne kültürkültür ortaya atla
şekerim bütün kültür yani onlar zamanda
tekerlek buldurmak tekerleği tekerleği
tekerleği bu kadar ona mı
Evet etimiz matematiğe olurdu veye şeydi
sayılar akıllı sayıları güzel onlar da
astronomi astroloji burçlar düşün ki
onların verdiği adlı biz kullanıyoruz
Salih müşteri hala yani çok büyük şey
hem astronomi matematik hem diğer
şeylerden mevcut Aslında dünyadaki
uygarlığının temelini Zehra Evet
teminatlar uygarlığı yöntemi yok
ücretsiz Cad düş memlüklerde Bu temel
şeydir başla Yunanlılar görev yerlere
Şimdi bunu yerine şeyler temellerini ama
maalesef diyorlar yapamıyoruz Çünkü şey
yıllardan beri yüzyıllardan beri bir
sebep şey dedik temiz yılan dedi kim
bu verid Elimizi geldik memleketlerde
halka dönük Süper Lig şeyi başka yerde
yok bizdeki gibi inanılmaz mı söylediği
bebek yok ama bu bir arka Köyü için
böyle değil Eğer çıkarsam bizim bütün
şimdi yazılan yazıların hepsi bitecek
diyorlar inanılmaz Peki hocam sürümü
sümeroloji bilme sümeroloji bitirmek
ihtisaslaşmak Sizinde müzecilik
deneyiminiz var müzeden şimdi Azer bir
hikaye atıcı çekerim yani bence sizin
öğretmenliğini Tamam ama Dil ve Tarih
Coğrafya Fakültesi ne girmeniz ile
birlikte Her şey bambaşka Baba olmuş ya
hayatım Tabii alsın
var yani hiç bilmediğin hiç duymadım Bir
konuya girdik ondan sonra biz bir gün
oldu kırkta ben ve arkadaşlara ben şimdi
bize hocamız sitoloji çocuğumuz ikimize
de üniversitede kalıp doktora yapmamızı
çizgi fetti 3metre kabul etmedik Ben
gelmeyecektim adım koca Üniversitesi
kalmadı ben ne kadarını arkadaşlar öyle
biz ikimize bizim müziği tayin ediyor
Biz müze bilmiyoruz tablet görmemiş
hiçbir şey düşün Bu vaziyette de babam
çok kızı bir şey kariyeri bırakıp da
bize hikayeme yani Ben oradaki bizim
oradaki heyecanlı da sabredemez siz bu
saatten tabletleri ayırırız dolara
Diyoruz ki
bu burada kuyu dolapları yerleştir
taraftan tercümeyi göğüs bir taraftan
yayınlıyoruz bir taraftan dışarıdan
gelenler onlarla beraber çalışmaya
başladık Ben Atsız böyle o Azam bir şey
Akademi çalışma onun düşünüyorum İsa
krem er11 defa geldi Onunla bütün
Sümeyye gibi tabletlerin köprü etmek
kolay değil onları geçmiş onları yaptık
ve hasıl yani oh şey bize hayatı benim
için en büyük Çek bir profesör olmadık
öptüm bana almadık nasıl oldu Sonra
Atatürk'ün bir şey vardır isteği ve bu
Sümerbank iki bak bakılır koymuştu bu
konuların halka inmesi
bu hafta bunları ilgili toplanması
okunmasini istiyordu Ben şimdi onu
biliyorum dedim ki ben halka gün yapıyor
diyeceğim bu kadar bir kimim var
yazıyoruz birikimin varsa ya halka dönük
ezeceğim işte oyuna başı başa kreme
birçok şey Kıramer kendi kitabını
Kıramer tarih kitabı var O zaman 15-cc
tercüme edilmişti Maze Sen de yap O
benim indireceğim saptandığı hesaptan
dolma çay yok yazmıyorsun bunları kendim
yaptım diye bana şey yaptı zorladı
rahmetli değil onları Ben başladım
yaptık onları sonra gö
bu yayınlandı gönderdim çok güzel bir
mektup yazmıştı bu çok büyük bir iş
yaptın Sen çünkü sümerlerin Türk olduğu
konuşuluyor Bu ilerde bekledi ispat
İzlemeyecek doğru yalan bir şey değil mi
bunun için Atatürk'ün dediğini yaptın
geçebiliriz Evet gebeliklerin
sevdiğinizi de yapmış Evet iki ay
Örümcek Adam gelsin şimdi işte o bunu
Tabi o da birşey oldu bana Ben de dedim
ki ben Bunlar diş yapılarak yazacağım
bir başladık tutulduğuna sonra bir Afiye
arkaya gelmeye başlıyor Böylece mutluyum
ne olsa da neler altüst olsa da bir
şeyler de istediği düşünüyoruz maalesef
maalesef değil mi
ya ben çok üzüldüm eğitim İlkim çok fena
bu yazık oluyor çocuklarımı adam beni ya
okumaya bile bu şey diyorum üzüldüğüm
yana çok üzülüyorum yani başka şeyler
diyeceğim ama benim için Emin iyiyim
Çünkü Çüş küçük çocuklar yavaş var O
baksana liseye gelmiş çocuk şey bilmiyor
diyor döktün işte bekliyorum bilmiyor
diyorsun matematik testi Yani ben buna
çok üzülüyorum şimdi bir kere bütün
kızları itmek lazım şu Çağdaş yaşamı
Türkan Saylan yapmak mı mı çok büyükmüş
yok Evet maalesef onu şey demiyor Şimdi
bu eğitimle eşitliği sağlamak zorundayız
iyi kim çok eğlenelim kadında ve erkekte
Bu hepsinde İlkim lazım eğitim olmazsa
olmaz Bak bu Atatürk zamanındaki Oo için
le le bugün kadınlarımız o zaman
kadınlarımız taşıp içindeydi okuma yazma
okuma yazma bilmiyordu bugün
kadınlarımız dünya çöpünde ütüler alan
her alanda sanatta ticarette ona çözüm
medyada birşeyde eğilimde ve hem bilim
Hey elimde her alanda öptüler Allah
rüyada ben bu da çok seviyorum çok çok
seviyorum Siz ben Dur şey yapmıyor baş
acıktı buraya geldikten sonra bir de şey
başarılı olan kadınlarımız veya
başkalarında çocukların ya videosu oldu
böyle kocaman geldim Ne
bir buçukta şey başarılı insanlarımız
var Onun için ben çok mutluyum çok
kızdım bir şey var Hep ki göstermesini
bilmek Allah kabir girme tepki
göstermeyen diyecek olmuş ya E şimdi bir
Amerikalı Senatör sormuşlar on mektup
alıyorsun herhangi bir şey Yapı atarım
50 mektubu alırsam düşünüyorum yüz
mektup alırsan öyle mi yaparım şimdi biz
de hiçbir zaman biz tepki göstermedim bu
insanlar acaba hocam korkuyor tembellik
ediyor bilmem ne Ben bunu size sormak
istememiştim ama sonra da tutamadım
kendimi arıyor musunuz Toprak dedi
aramızda olurdun eküriniz ve o
o siyah o programı çok özlüyorum değil
mi Ama biliyor musun geldi bana ilk o o
sen ya böyle bir program yapalım Sen
kaçık nasıl benim Doktor yaşına kadar
Bey televizyona çıkmışım dedim ben nasıl
olur yaparım videonun noktası işte hocam
sizin hayatınız hep dönüm noktaları oldu
diyorum oldu yani 90 yaşında ben
şaşırdım Olmaz böyle dedim olurdu
olmazdı çıktık oldu be öyle dedi
inanmazsın şeyi zor bekliyordum programı
değil mi Ama hazırlık yok Ne o bana
şeysin duasını gidiyoruz bir Hanım dedi
burada da siz ne zaman Konuşmaya
başlayın ben hemen kağıt kalem aldım
itici Özgün kitap ismi veriyorsunuz şey
biliyor bizi Aslında o
bu bedax İstanbul aracılığı ile birlikte
Toprak dedeye Veda etmiş olalım mı